hey man
what's going on it's bill bird it's time
for the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast and uh
just checking in on [ __ ] you
what's going on how are you
oh [ __ ] it's thursday dude it's [ __ ]
payday
gonna [ __ ] go to eat to deangelo's
and get a [ __ ] steak and cheese
[ __ ] barbecue chips i always hated
barbecue chips
never tasted good you know you just go
you gotta go
with the originals that's what i do once
a week i go out and i get my cell phone
i got myself a nice [ __ ] sandwich
right
with an orange fanta and chips
that's what i did yesterday yesterday
afternoon i had a little bit of a window
because this because this is the new me
now i realize that um i'm [ __ ]
i do too much hey bill
you do it too much why don't you [ __ ]
take it down a little bit yeah i'm a
[ __ ] lunatic
you could give me 24 hours off and i
will
before i even get my [ __ ] foot my
pasty freckled foot out of bed i will
think of things that will tie me up
until at least four in the afternoon
oh i got the whole day off oh maybe i'll
do this and after this
that's what the [ __ ] i do
because if i don't fill up the day then
i have to sit there and be alone with my
own thoughts
that's what it is i always thought for
years i was driven
i thought i was i thought i was an
achiever i wasn't
i wasn't i was just depressed so i was
trying to get away from it
because like all good german irish
people you're not going to sit there
and live with your emotions you're going
to [ __ ] run just in front of them you
know
your emotions are like some overbearing
dad that's trying to live his sports
dream through you
making you do road work at like five in
the morning he's got his head out the
window yelling at you and you're just
trying to stay a little bit in front of
the car
so maybe the yelling doesn't sound so
loud
that's what the [ __ ] i've been doing so
i cannot tell you how hard it is for me
to just sit down in an
afternoon and eat a sandwich
with a bag of chips and an orange fanta
and not
reach for my phone
like to just [ __ ] sit there like i i
i can't do it like i kept going okay you
leave the phone alone leave the phone
alone
and my hand was like a [ __ ] crackhead
i'm just saying hey let's
go over and [ __ ] reach for the thing
um
yeah it's pretty wild man it's pretty
wild realizing you know i always knew i
was [ __ ] up but like to realize
i'm this [ __ ] up this far into it i
mean who's ken hool i'm like the 11th
and 12th hole at this point
i didn't know i was gonna have to go
back and [ __ ] change all the
mechanics of my swing here i had no idea
i had no idea but no i had a great talk
with my uh
my wife after we had a we had a nice we
had an oh we had a nice one
we had a nice one um
yeah nice one but you know i went for a
walk that's the new me i was like you
know what i'm just i'm just gonna go for
a walk what am i gonna do here you know
what i mean
this is like being at the dmv and
expecting
to get a satisfactory answer i just said
you know what i'm just gonna go for a
[ __ ] walk
okay i'm just gonna go for a walk i'll
listen to some music
you know and i'll just keep walking
until i don't care anymore so you know
what
two and a half three miles later you
know i start turning around i start
coming back feeling dehydrated
yeah my organs shutting down
you know prioritize whatever the hell i
was upset about and i came in i just had
this great conversation with my wife
and we got on the same [ __ ] page so
um
i don't know i'm gonna try to slow down
a little bit if you can [ __ ] believe
it
i've spent the last [ __ ] 30 years
just [ __ ] working my ass off
which has been fun and it's been great
but i'm also realizing like
do i want to be that laying on my bed
what'd you do
i [ __ ] i [ __ ] worked every [ __ ]
side [ __ ] you know i don't know about
that
i would like a few more days of just
sitting down on a porch what the [ __ ] is
the purpose of having a porch if you
never sit on it
right i don't know
i'm all over the place i stopped doing
yoga
[ __ ] shoulders [ __ ] up again i just
can't wait for this whole stupid goddamn
lockdown [ __ ] to be over
i don't even give a [ __ ] anymore cause
like at this point when they have like a
vaccine and people still don't want to
take it it's at that point you just
gotta tap out and be like all right just
you know people still thinking it's just
a flu all right
go out and go get it then i don't give a
[ __ ] i've been vaccinated
i i don't give a [ __ ] i'll just wear
like extra long turtlenecks oh like that
character and that stupid [ __ ]
com not stupid legendary comic strip
what the hell was it
oh bazooka joe i thought it was that
other one with jughead and all of them
um anyway sorry just [ __ ] empty in my
brain here like [ __ ]
was it almost ten or six in the morning
um i was watching some true crime
with my wife last night i don't know why
she's like i think snl did a sketch
about that how women like watching those
true crime shows
um but we just sit there and we watch
and
we we i swear to god so many of them
we don't even agree with what they came
up with
um as far as like who the [ __ ] did it
there's just some [ __ ] twisted people
out there who like rather than
breaking up with somebody they kill him
i just like there were a lot of [ __ ]
psychos out there you know like who's
kid who like
breaking up with somebody just [ __ ]
sucks
and if you're listening right now you
know what i mean like
listen i had to break up with people in
in my
past and the thought definitely went
through my head would be like what if
they just got into an accident and died
so then i wouldn't have to have this
conversation then he'd be like ah man i
can't take that that's that's the
difference
but as psycho goes hey wait a minute
right do you realize how psychotic you
are
that you think that killing somebody and
then trying to get away with that
is going to be easier than just sitting
down with somebody
and being like hey you know what i'm not
happy
you know i thought this was love love
but this was just more like
friendship love
and you know
i want more than that and that's what
you got to say you can't be like i think
you deserve
more oh [ __ ] don't [ __ ] out then just
[ __ ]
keep your foot to the floor and be like
i want more than that
all right this is about me
i love like you i like love you
that's not enough for me
you know i love my buddy but i don't
want to marry him
you know it's kind of a love like that
that's the way you go you know what i
mean like right now if you're listening
to this
podcast and you're on your way to home
depot to buy a tarp
because you think you're gonna you're
not gonna get away with it
just [ __ ] break up with them you
[ __ ] lunatic
you're gonna find somebody else um
anyways well you know this is what
happens when you go to bed watching
[ __ ] one murder show murder story
after another my wife
i don't know what she said told me that
she likes to she
that she watches it because as a woman
like you think that
i guess you know what would i do if i
was in this situation how to recognize
these signs so i guess i kind of
understand that
remember a long time ago uh i had this
thought like
like as a man like you know when you
watch those behind the scenes
in prison you know when you see somebody
going to jail
you know and you put yourself in that
position going how the [ __ ] would i
survive that
first thought how would i prevent from
myself from becoming somebody's
boyfriend
or getting gang raped getting stabbed
like that mindset that you go into i
finally realized one day like oh you
know what women have to do that just
leaving their house
considering there's so many [ __ ] guys
out there
that are stronger than them and are
psychos right so
i guess so she i guess that's she
watches that show because she's trying
to learn
what not to do or signs
i don't know if you listen to the
beginning of this podcast i sound like
i'm out of my [ __ ] mind maybe she's
worried about me
um anyway we're gonna plow ahead plow
forward after that one
um so listen to this [ __ ] so i
uh my continuing saga of playing with
the idea of buying myself my dream
pickup truck
a ford f250 and um
i just kept flipping back and forth on
that color velocity blue
you know it wasn't the blue i thought it
was gonna be and then i went down there
and i hated the blue and then i came
back and looked at i said no it's
actually kind of a cool blue
it is [ __ ] blue though right so
finally the other day a buddy of mine
knew a guy that had
the [ __ ] raptor version of the ford
f-250
four-door just like this thing was like
the size of a [ __ ] battleship
and he swung by my house and i looked at
it and uh
it was a beautiful truck but i re i
realized that that blue isn't for me
it's a that that is a
hey look at me blue
you know where i'm looking for more of a
hey
you know [ __ ] off you know
nothing to see here blue so i think i
want the anti-matter blue
whatever this is just silly [ __ ] this is
just a silly
dream of a married man with two [ __ ]
kids
that i i think i'm actually gonna get
that truck but whatever i i do it every
day every day i go on the website i can
build
my dream f 250 now in under like [ __ ]
35 seconds
i use that to [ __ ] i know exactly
what the [ __ ] i want
um but so anyway i called up a buddy of
mine
who has an inn at ford and can get me a
you know a good deal and he said there's
something going on
there's a chip or something that the
fords need
and like the production has slowed down
so if i was gonna get one that um
it would be a 2022 at this point if i
was going to special order one
so which means 2022 there might be some
new colors
so now i'm waiting to see what the new
colors are it's funny they only have
like [ __ ]
you know eight nine ten colors and if
you go back back in the day
i mean they had like there was like
[ __ ] like 40 colors you could choose
from
two-tone and all of that stuff these
[ __ ] corporate [ __ ] they just took
the fun
out of everything
man i can't imagine like
i would think that that would be fun in
the
uh i mean who knows they probably don't
even have people like that
like literally physically paint them
does anybody work on it at ford
or gmc chevy one of these [ __ ] places
dodge like how do they go about is it
just a robot now
goes and paints it because i remember
back in the day
when um
when i used to watch when fast and loud
was on
and i used to watch casey paint cars i
remember him saying after a while how he
[ __ ] you know when they just wanted
to do a patina thing
how boring it was for him just to do a
[ __ ] clear coat
i mean it's like writing with invisible
ink basically
um and how you know
excited he would get when he got a
little creative leeway
to pick a cool color you know
and basically tap into the whole [ __ ]
reason
why he you know someone who paints cars
gets into it
because you look at a car and you and
you you
connect to it the color that would look
the most badass on it um
for the life of me i don't understand
why corporate people
just force the masses to choose between
white gray or black
you know they'll give you a red and
maybe a blue and then you're just
done all the [ __ ] colors in the
universe they're like yeah go [ __ ]
yourself
these are the these that's the colors
um i mean in the 70s you could buy an
orange pickup truck
two-toned they had something
called like [ __ ] you know let me
listen to these [ __ ] colors man
i'm just gonna we'll just pick a year
what do you guys like yeah you like
let's say 1973
ford f 250
colors all right
jesus christ look it up and right there
there's a [ __ ] bright orange one all
right here we go
ford truck color
of course this is on [ __ ] ebay oh
zoom in here we go
all right first of all there was one two
three four five
times one two three four five six
seven eight nine
nine times five there was 45 [ __ ]
colors
to choose from now you couldn't get
these in all
maybe those let's see here one one two
three four
five six seven times five this is for
four trucks so you had 35 colors to
choose from
they had wind blue baja beige
winter green saddle tan
tampico yellow i've seen that with white
it's [ __ ] gorgeous
yankee blue durango tan
tidewater aqua rangoon
red pure white
uh fiesta tan boxwood green a buddy of
mine has one of those has a boxwood
green with white it's [ __ ] gorgeous
sequoia brown poly
hot ginger that's the one i would have
got
paulie i like to think i'm a hot ginger
diamond green
aspen tan royal maroon
what a maroon um
midnight blue poly holly green
brook blue poly mill valley green
wimbledon white that's it classic candy
apple red
bright lime imperial red shell white
bahama blue limestone green poly diamond
blue
chrome yellow this is the last
one here c pine green scandia green poly
mallard green harbor blue
i mean what the [ __ ] and then you could
get like two-tone
combos all of that [ __ ]
now they just got iconic silver gray
black
white i mean they give them cool names
for the
you know i don't know
i would think that that would be more
exciting
and you would you would get more people
to come and buy i also had another idea
you know how there was a while for a
while there right
this is back when music videos were
bigger and i think rappers had a little
more
influence you know
i don't know i'm also not in that world
but like i just think rock stars and
musicians had i think more influence on
like
fashion and style and that type of [ __ ]
back when mtv was playing videos and
everybody wasn't just you know
on their phones and on the internet and
you know whatever
but i remember like jay-z had his own
sneaker the
s-dots the sean carter's right i
remember the only reason i knew that
because i was on tour with charlie
murphy and he bought like [ __ ]
five different pairs so
and they were a big success right and i
was always wondering look you look at
kanye west and the yeezys those are a
big success i've never understood
why why uh
a car company never partnered up
with a rapper or a rock star or a
country star
and built like the [ __ ]
whatever like a a car like the same way
they had the sean carter sneaker you
could have
shot car whatever car he's into porsches
mercedes
country star like the [ __ ] uh
travis tritt [ __ ] ford f2f i don't
know anybody country music
you know and just you get somebody
who's a famous musician
who is so into cars or trucks that they
literally
think they have a problem like that
level of passion
and then the designers of the cars or
the trucks just
ask them what's your favorite truck what
is missing
and there you go like they had the eddie
bauer bronco for all those years
i'll tell you right now i'd bring back
the full-size bronco
in that little first thing i would do is
that little console in the middle
you know you could also it's also a
cooler
you say
no i know cause then you'd be promoting
drinking and driving
but that option's only available if you
live way out in the [ __ ] sticks
um hey what why can get people out here
ride a motorcycle without a helmet i
can't have a full-size ford bronco with
the cooler right by my elbow
i mean [ __ ] is this america what
um yeah so anyway
um
i mean that's what i would do i'd bring
back
i'd have way more colors to [ __ ]
choose from
it's so [ __ ] nuts like you can go
onto like adidas website and literally
design your own shelter
these goddamn cars it's just black white
gray
go [ __ ] yourself supposed to be excited
that
ford f250 has one custom color
you know i know all you [ __ ] hipsters
and [ __ ] young people
dude just go out and get a rap
i guess you could do but doesn't that
like one night i guess that doesn't void
the warranty because if you went out and
got a whole custom paint job and they
really did it right they'd have to take
the whole [ __ ] thing apart and then
there goes your warranty
and then you got to hope that the paint
shop is going to put the thing back
together
better than they are at the factory and
they're not they're not gonna they just
don't
they're not gonna be better than those
[ __ ] soulless
robots sorry all right
um i watched a couple of games last
night i watched uh the ending of the
edmonton oiler winnipeg jet game
i love watching edmonton i love that
[ __ ] team man
it's a fun goddamn team to watch
you know aside from the obvious um i
almost said taylor hall
uh connor mcdavid and but like you know
dry sidle
uh i just like that whole team nugent
hopkins nurse i like that defenseman i
just a
fun [ __ ] team to watch they're never
out of it
um and i also like just watching
canada versus canada hockey just feels
like the most purest form of the sport
even though you know it's
a bunch of russians and europeans for
the most part um
it's still fun though i watched the
ninth inning of the angels versus the
rangers i'm really into baseball this
year man
i think trying to slow my [ __ ]
psychotic goddamn brain down
has um
drawn me back to baseball but the red
sox man
16 9. in first place
four and a half game lead over the
yankees as a true red sox fan i
completely ignore the devil raising the
blue jays who are three games and four
games out
you know it's not like they haven't had
great teams bray's are great every year
it seems
[ __ ] orioles man always in the
basement
when the [ __ ] are they gonna turn that
thing around they were such a great team
when i was growing up
60s to 70s in the 80s
you know they were going to the world
series it felt like every four or five
years
um they wanted what they wanted 66 they
wanted
70. uh they lost at 79
then they won in 83. and then they just
it just the whole [ __ ] thing went
away
um royals are [ __ ]
tearing it up 15 and eight i love the
[ __ ] royals
way back in the day um
jesus christ they're just going to run
away with that division huh
it looks like it 15 and 8 and the white
sox are 12 and 10
and then everybody else is under
is under 500 the tribe are 11 and 12
twins are 18 8 and 15 and the tigers are
eight and 16. ah
that was my dad's team growing up he
liked the indians and the tigers
uh and then the athletics look at them
playing 600 ball and then the astros you
know what they should do
they should [ __ ] their their team
song should be
get it on bang-a-gone get it on
i love everybody thinks they're [ __ ]
cheaters i just saw something the other
yesterday i literally saw something
yesterday
whitey ford the great [ __ ] new york
yankee
used to scuff the the baseball with his
wedding ring
every game and then put mud in it i mean
just everybody was doing something
to get a [ __ ] advantage
you know
the whole [ __ ] thing your team cheats
but mine doesn't oh jesus christ
santa claus comes to my house but he
doesn't come to your house
um anyway all right let me do a little
little [ __ ] read here
let me do a little read here oh look who
it is
indochino uh discuss how little things
are small gestures can mean a lot in a
relationship share an example
oh my god little things little things
are the biggest things
ever you know in a
in a relationship you know what i mean
before you get out of bed spooning with
your wife
hugging her telling you that you love
her
you know your wife you know getting off
her [ __ ] ass once every [ __ ] three
years and making you a sandwich just
something little like that it's just
it's amazing
ah jesus you know one of the great
little things you could do
the person you're with the end of the
day you [ __ ] give them a foot rub
especially if you're old jesus christ
people next door think there's a porno
happening it's like nah she's just
rubbing my foot
all right sorry all right um love is
defined by the little things that matter
the most within nocino the perfect
custom
wedding suit with every detail accounted
for is more affordable than you might
think
oh you got to go sinatra and get your
own [ __ ] tuxedo here
share a story of a surprising way a
couple you know
has met or an interesting way they show
their love
i got nothing on that one wait a minute
what
i i mean i don't know i don't ask people
about their love life
so how did you two meet
[ __ ] that's such a great question if you
ever if there's ever parties anymore
so how did you chew me can you believe
this weather
um every every piece is made to your
exact measurement
and you can customize every detail i
mean i think that should be enough
that's
that's amazing right there from
breathable linen fabrics
for warm weather weddings georgia
to statement linings you can create a
suit that fits
in your style perfectly say a little bit
of a little something about yourself
you're not an off-the-rack kind of
person you got
style you're a purse you need people to
see you
see me um
the best part indochino's suits start at
just 299
with all customizations included
300 bucks you're walking down the street
with a suit no one else has
shop the wedding collection or book a
virtual style consultation
at indochino.com right now you can get
off any purchase of 3.99 or more
by using the code bur at checkout that's
off a purchase of 3.99 399
or more at indochino.com n
i-n-d-o-c-h-i-n-o
dot com india november
delta oscar charlie hotel india november
oscar.com
promo code burr all right you got to go
custom
suit if you could do a custom suit for
[ __ ] what
3.99 minus 50 bucks for 249 no 349 sorry
suck it meth
it's a great way to start the marriage
off she sees you coming down holy [ __ ]
he gives a [ __ ]
he cares
you know and that's also a good way to
find out if you're marrying a psycho
why'd you get a custom suit huh is this
somebody else are you trying to track
somebody else already then you can be
like hey
does anybody have any [ __ ] reasons
this guy doesn't want to get married i
do
i do because she can't handle my
indochino custom [ __ ] suit okay
and if you can't handle that that is the
tip of the iceberg
and there is no [ __ ] way i'm sharing
a bed with you for the rest of my life
that's really what it is that's what it
is right there all right
here we go man living alone on an
italian island
to leave after 32 years i've been living
alone on an island mentally since 1974.
jesus christ used to see this guy man
he looks like he's been living alone on
an island and they did nothing to try to
make him look better
then they photoshopped some [ __ ]
island behind him
this is what people look like before
there was lotion
my god it looks like you unwrapped a
mummy uh
i'm too vain to oh he's 81 years old you
know what he doesn't look that bad my
fault i thought he was like 36.
well that would mean he got to the
island at [ __ ] 32
wait a minute wait a minute
not 32 32.
he's 81 i'm all [ __ ] up here four
he'd be 36 years old that's what it is
all right so he's 81
minus 32. he moved there at 49.
yeah i can see that yep
if you're gonna live alone on an island
right around 49
i can see that that's a good age to move
you know you do it when you're too young
it's just like all right
you don't know how to talk to chicks you
you're [ __ ] you're freaking out too
much
you you're thinking you're thinking
you're getting too far ahead of the game
you know but at 49.
okay you gave life a shot
you tried to you tried it okay
i'm gonna get that one-bedroom apartment
i'm i'm gonna go to ikea and i'm gonna
buy
some stuff you know when you're sitting
there am i feeling it
is there a sense of happiness and
fulfillment not yet
now oh what are those crocs is that what
everybody's wearing i'll [ __ ] get
some of those
hey i got a girlfriend let's let's go to
the olive garden
you gave it you gave it a i'll get into
the local team
i'll buy the merch i'll know all the
stats
you gave it a shot
and it didn't take and usually
at that point you got two choices well
you got three
you know one is to roll credits which
you don't want to do
second you know
you turn to some sort of [ __ ]
mind-altering [ __ ]
to numb the pain which is never good on
three the healthiest of them all
you just [ __ ] walk away from society
let's listen to this guy's story
all right uh mauro morandi 81
moved to budelli off northern sardinia
in 1989.
mr gorbachev tear down that well i don't
know when the [ __ ] that it was right
around then right
well he was already out by 89 that was
george bush not gonna do it right
um mike dukakis sticking his head out
the [ __ ] tank last year however
mr morandy said the owner of the island
which is famed for its pink beach
wanted him to relocate
well i mean you know for a guy that owns
his own island to let a guy live there
rent free for 32 years
is pretty [ __ ] cool before he gets
vilified
um the the guy on the island
uh mr morandy said i will leave hoping
that in the future
budelli will be protected as i have
protected
protected it for 32 years he wrote on
facebook
on sunday oh he loved the island in
nature i like this guy
speaking to bbc outlook in 2018 the
former physical education
teacher i was a gym teacher said he had
always been a bit of a rebel
i was quite fed up with a lot of things
about our society
consumerism and the political situation
in italy
yeah he must have been real fed up if he
walked away from the best food on the
planet
mr morandy said i decided to move to a
desert island
in polynesia away from all civilization
i wanted to start a new life close to
nature
this guy actually gets life as [ __ ]
nuts as this guy seems this guy
gets life although it would have been
nice if he brought somebody with them
you know or maybe he gets life more than
me
that this guy can actually [ __ ] be
alone
anyway after beginning that their
journey by sea he and a number of his
friends oh they had a friends that
were gonna do this with him he and a
number of friends landed on the italian
archipelago uh i don't know what to say
of
la madalina
where they plan to work and make money
to fund the rest of their travels but
after arriving
on boudelli and meeting the island
guardian
who was about to retire mr morandy
decided to stay
and has remained ever since looking
after the island and speaking to taurus
jesus christ can you imagine if you
[ __ ] pull you didn't know he was
there it's a deserted island and
obviously this guy comes walking out
from behind the ferns
is that tom hanks are they doing a
sequel
um however he has faced a number of
eviction threats over the years
in 2020 the president of la medel
de la national park fabrizio for news
vanessa uh told cnn that mr
morandy had carried out illegal
alterations to his hut oh for [ __ ]
sakes
a former radio station dating back to
world war
ii that's what he lived in how [ __ ]
cool is that a petition calling on
italian government to allow him to stay
gathered more than 70 000 signatures but
on sunday mr morand he
announced the decision to leave telling
the guardian newspaper that he would
move to a small flat
on the nearby island of uh
la madeleine my life won't change too
much
i'll still see the sea
you know wasn't that a night that was a
nice heartwarming story
you know i know he never found love he
did he found it with the sea
in the [ __ ] island
jesus christ i mean what i want to talk
to that guy about his [ __ ] existence
just waking up not being like ah [ __ ] i
got to do this podcast and then i got to
go run over here then i gotta rehab my
[ __ ] shoulder
and all of this [ __ ] you know
i gotta oh what are we instagram and
everybody's going over to tick tock i
gotta go over to [ __ ] tech talk now
he didn't have to deal with any of that
[ __ ]
you just [ __ ] wake up be like all
right
i think i'll climb up that tree and have
some coconut water for breakfast
then every once in a while being excited
when taurus showed up
all of them trying to get away from
jeggings and [ __ ] crocs
and flat screen tvs
that they get on a boat and they come
out there and they see him happy as hell
living in a [ __ ] world war two radio
hut
and that guy gave people you know great
perspective good for him
um all right that's it the whole
family's gonna be getting up soon
so i gotta go do that [ __ ] oh billy
taking it easy oh billy's slowing it
down a little bit
you know before my fall tour before it
gets crazy again
um what is today today's it's almost the
end of the month right it's got to be
what the 29th 30th what is
the 29th all right there you go
two months without cigars or anything
else i'm thinking maybe i'll have a
cigar when i [ __ ]
watch the kentucky derby although my
first thought is but then dude you're
gonna start that [ __ ] back up again
um we'll see
we'll see what the [ __ ] happens i don't
know um anyway
um that's the podcast i was just
checking in on you just like that guy in
the island
like you just pulled up hope
everything's good with you
i hope you get a chance to sit on a
porch and eat a sandwich
you know just [ __ ] chill out not look
at your [ __ ] phone
you know because i'm so self-involved
that i think that you suffer from the
exact same things that i do
because the universe exists between my
ears
sorry all right have a great weekend you
[ __ ] i'll talk to you on monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
april 29th 2013. how are you
how you doing i am in a [ __ ]
phenomenal mood
absolutely i'm in a great god damn mood
you know why
you know why because i'm not even mad
right now that my cell phone is ringing
this [ __ ] early in the podcast i'm
not
i'm not um you know what's funny that
cell phone just made me completely lose
my train of thought that's how
simplistic my brain is it goes in a
straight line
one [ __ ] thing knocks it off track
and i just i i forget where i was going
why am i in a great mood oh i know why
because the celtics
showed that they have [ __ ] hot
and the lakers lost got swept
disgraced humiliated and i loved every
goddamn second of it
you know and you know why i am i okay
i'm back on track i feel [ __ ]
vindicated
after all these laker fans you know were
tweeting me
facebooking me myspacing me
friendstering me
saying that i'm just a hater you know
which is the classic thing that somebody
says when they can't refute any points
that you made they go are you just a
hater
it's when i told them that the guy that
they
constantly sit there and call enchant
mvp at is is a [ __ ]
cancer on that team
it's a [ __ ] cancer and they just
can't see it
because i'm not saying all of them but
just because they that everybody plays
these fantasy [ __ ] football baseball
[ __ ] all they look at is stats
all right let me tell you something
laker fans
when you're not eating your pot cookies
and body [ __ ] boogie boarding or
whatever the [ __ ] it is you guys do
you know when you're not laying back at
the chair at the [ __ ] dental office
getting botox in your [ __ ] head even
though you're only 19 years old
why don't you just put yourself in the
position of the other players on the
lakers
all right did you wake the [ __ ] up get
out of the sun
stop frying up your goddamn brain and
just use a little bit of common sense
listen i know after the games when kobe
walks off with 10 seconds left during a
loss because he he got his 37 points
you know then afterwards when they ask
the other lakers
in front of the camera and they go oh
you know how did you feel about that and
then they just go well you know
kobe he's uh he's a competitor you know
he's one of the best that uh ever played
the game and uh
i mean he wants to win i mean we all do
and uh that didn't happen tonight
unfortunately and uh all we know what to
do is to just
i can [ __ ] do it you just keep
working hard and did you uh have any
sort of uh
did it annoy you at all they walked off
court nope no it didn't bother me
um you know every guy uh has a different
personality i mean you can just [ __ ]
gracefully navigate that minefield
and just say all that [ __ ] i would
[ __ ] give a million dollars if i had
it to listen
to the other lakers on the team their
cell phone conversations when they leave
the staples center
talking to their [ __ ] brothers you
know
going all paul mccartney and john lennon
[ __ ] sick of them
you know they're coming out of there and
they're [ __ ] range rovers
and their [ __ ] hundred thousand
dollars mercedes just driving out going
can you [ __ ] believe
that [ __ ] what they can [ __ ]
you know i'm wide open i'm wide open
kobe
right here right here yo
[ __ ] guy takes a turnaround jumper
with three guys hanging off on
10 feet behind the arc
i don't care that it went in
i'm telling you right now dude what the
[ __ ] would you do okay if you were at
some 4-h club
and you're supposed to build a tree fort
you know
then you're holding up the board and
you're supposed to hammer on both sides
one [ __ ] just hammers in his side then
just [ __ ] walks away and the whole
thing collapses out of the tree and he
just walks away
and everybody else at camp is laughing
at you during the loss and he's [ __ ]
already back eating a popsicle stick in
the [ __ ] log cabin how would you feel
what would you be saying you know
i'll tell you if it was televised around
the [ __ ] world
to all the 4hs and your goal was to
continue being in 4hs you do exactly
what
the other [ __ ] laker people do you
just sit there going like
well you know uh he's uh
he loves building tree forts and uh it's
really in his heart and when things
don't go well he gets upset
and uh you know all we know how to do is
just to get out there tomorrow actually
your
voice would be way higher actually all
we know is to uh go out there tomorrow
and i try to build another tree fort
i love it so the guy he gets injured
all right now you can actually sit down
and maybe watch the lakers you get maybe
get to watch steve nash do what the [ __ ]
he does distribute the goddamn ball
rather than pass it to kobe
and then sit there you know i don't know
what
what do you do with that after you pass
it to kobe i mean you might as well just
[ __ ] sit down
you know take a little cat nap or
whatever
i was actually looking forward to that
[ __ ] and what happens
what hap what is the cancer what does
this guy do
he starts tweeting during the game
criticizing the [ __ ] coach
laker fence you can't read through the
lines when his coach said uh he's a fan
now that's what fans do
and then kobe like laughs it off that
right read between the lines he's saying
this guy's one of the biggest [ __ ] i've
ever had to coach in my life
even when he's not on the court he's
still [ __ ] up the chemistry of the
team
all right did bill russell ever tweet
during his celtic career
all right you get the point you know
what i'm saying i feel vindicated how
about those celtics
how about those old ass celtics i was
really nervous that they were gonna that
they were gonna get swept
and um i don't know
i i i gotta be honest with you i i
didn't watch one second
of the celtics series i've i
i can only pick one sport you know
so i've been watching the bruins and i
gotta tell you man i have never been so
[ __ ] frustrated with the team in my
life
jesus christ the first two periods we
come out we play great
play great we always score every [ __ ]
game i watch we score two
[ __ ] goals and we look phenomenal
until right towards the end of the
second period or the third period the
whole thing just falls apart
i don't know what's going on i'm
actually i just think it's one of these
years
one of these years where you ca there's
no way i can't figure out what the
problem is
nobody can figure out what the problem
is and unfortunately somebody's going to
have to pay for it
because when you don't get where you
want to be either the coach has to lose
his job
or somebody has to get [ __ ] traded um
i don't know it was like watching the uh
i mean this is obviously not as bad but
a few years ago when the red sox
when the wheels fell off with them and
rather than everybody just sitting down
being like all right we won two world
series
we obviously know what the [ __ ] we're
doing okay
let's try to figure this thing out
everybody started pointing fingers and
the whole [ __ ] thing disintegrates
and it was like watching van halen break
up you know
david lee roth left van halen brothers
go over this way
you know and and are they better for it
did they ever make a better album than
those first what four or five they never
did
they never did because they [ __ ] with
the chemistry
um so anyways this is the monday morning
podcast
i'm your wonderful host i'm bill burr
and i got a buddy of mine
up and coming comedian uh danny labelle
has a uh
has a new comedy album that's coming out
this isn't a commercial this is just i'm
just a nice little promotion for a
friend of mine
the name of the album is called some
kind of comedian um
april 30th tomorrow the album unless you
listen to this
years in the future then it's already
out but if you're listening to it today
april 30th tomorrow tuesday 2013 april
30th the album is out in stores
and it'll be on itunes amazon.com etc
it's recorded in scotland which i think
is cool
you know gives it a nice different
flavor at the uh glasgow comedy festival
danny labelle it's called some kind of
comedian uh check it out if you want
what's great it's as if it's on itunes
you can listen to some tracks if you
like it you can download it if you don't
you don't have to but either way don't
[ __ ] start bitching at me i like this
guy and i think he's funny okay
go [ __ ] yourselves all right back to the
podcast um
where the hell am i what the hell did i
want to talk about
after going on and on about that you
know i've been reading this daily mail
thing you guys go on this website
what's the deal with daily mail um
did i already get rid of it oh no there
it is
this is the most insane [ __ ] website
they just got they got i love it they
got stories all around
they got one here this this is a bad one
boy two
and ten month old brother died after
exhausted
australian mother left him in the shower
and fell asleep for 10 hours
jesus christ what the [ __ ] was she on
huh
i was really tired and i slept pretend
you don't sleep for 10 hours unless
you've been doing what
blow for three days i guess some people
can sleep that long
that's [ __ ] i mean i know i shouldn't
be laughing at this [ __ ]
that's a bad one then they got this
other story it says you've got a uh
you got a friend in me xena the warrior
puppy rescued as it was starving to
death now changing the life of an
autistic boy
and you got to see this picture of this
dog when they found it starving
it looks like a fossil with fur on it
it already looks like it's dead somehow
this thing comes back to life
and is now helping this kid that has
autism
all right so there's one for you cat
people
you ever found an emaciated fossil
looking [ __ ] cat
all right and you nursed it back to
health giving it milk
and whatever in a little box for it to
[ __ ] in the house
and give you that look like yeah you
deal with it like cats
always do all right do you think at the
end of that journey
that it would then [ __ ] help out some
autistic kid you think a cat cat doesn't
have a [ __ ] ability to do that
you know they don't because there are a
bunch of [ __ ] so there you go
the two debates have ended today
dogs are better people than cats and the
celtics have more heart than the lakers
that's just it
okay and i'm also gonna i'm also gonna
[ __ ] check off
kobe is not the [ __ ] mvp all right
kobe
is if you if fantasy football fantasy
basketball that's the [ __ ] guy you
want your goddamn team
he's not even in the game and he's still
affecting
he's got to sit there and tweet and
criticize his own goddamn coach
oh my god that guy earns the k you know
and [ __ ] um all right
on to some other [ __ ] here
and i know it's been a lot oh it's been
pretty much nothing
nothing but sports talk this week um
this one actually transcends sports
to show that everybody in sports is not
a [ __ ] meathead nba star
jason collins comes out as gay making
them him the first
openly homosexual athlete on a major
american sports team now other people
have come out but always after their
careers
and uh and i think it's [ __ ] great
i've said for years i wanted it to be a
football player who was the most [ __ ]
like
like a ray lewis level guy i always
thought that that would be [ __ ]
hilarious
just because not only because it's just
an extra level of way to talk [ __ ] to
fans of the other team
you know which i guess is probably
homophobic to be like even our gay guy
is kicking the [ __ ] out of you
you know like there's not some tough gay
dudes out there
so look at this i'm learning things too
here it is nba star jason collins came
out as gay today
in a revealing interview but how many
people are going to lose their jobs
trying to write a twitter joke about
this one
um or their endorsement with some
[ __ ] insurance company
uh making him the first professional
athlete in american sports
uh to come out as gay oh what somebody
else's
as a soccer player coming out oh jesus
that's an easy joke right there
i'm not going to step in that [ __ ]
minefield i'm not going to do it i'm
going to be mature throughout this
entire story
the 34 year old basketball player opened
up an interview with sports illustrated
amid much speculation about rumors that
the major athlete would be coming out of
the closet
uh the initial reports came from the
national football league as a number of
straight players said that they would
support a teammate
should they reveal they were gay yeah
why wouldn't you i got to tell you the
shower's got to be a little weird then
you know
hey is this is this [ __ ] dumb should
they have their own showers then
or at least pla pay a cover if they're
going to go into the shop
should they have to i'm going to open
this debate with my own morons should
they have to pay a cover charge
when they go into the shower with
everybody else
with all the other dudes on the team you
know
i mean what the [ __ ] what if i was
playing in the wnba they wouldn't let me
go in the shower
he's gonna walk in there with a stinger
right they would all be flipping out
that's a [ __ ] very ignorant
yet interesting point you know
everybody on your team is in shape
they're all got their abs and their pecs
going
you can't tell me that's not a [ __ ]
enjoyable experience
that would like be like me if i got to
walk in and shower with all these
victoria's secret models and they'll be
like ew
can i hear you creep what i'm just like
you
i also like wearing high-heeled shoes
with
feathers right
i don't know either way i'm [ __ ]
around i think it's great it's about
goddamn time
and uh i think it's [ __ ] hilario i
guess there's so many morons that are
sports fans that i
i wish that i was in a sports bar
when this came out and just watching
[ __ ] guys eyebrows and [ __ ]
getting all twisted up
what it's sports you're not supposed to
be gay
um i think it's great good for him
good on him who's he play for right now
i i never
30 oh the washington wizards come out as
gay oh my god did they
did they make the playoffs or not i have
no idea
i have no idea but i can guarantee you
somebody
somebody's gonna lose their job trying
to make a joke
or somebody's gonna uh oh jesus you know
all those bible belt people
if he ever plays a game down in like
[ __ ] if he plays the grizzly
they're gonna be standing outside the
team bus you are going to
hail that's when you know you're a [ __ ]
when when you're [ __ ]
you make one-syllable words two-syllable
you're going to hail
he's in bed um
what's the one and i always do the one
about the chick
i can't [ __ ] remember my brain's
fried people
i've been on the road this entire month
actually this entire [ __ ] year i
figured it out
and i can't even remember the numbers
we're like something like 17 or 18 weeks
into this year and i've been to like 20
cities
all right i really don't know what's
going on in the world this is how
[ __ ]
out of the loop i am i knew that there
was an explosion in texas and it took me
two three days before i
i read something that let me know
whether it was an accident
or another [ __ ] timothy mcveigh
psycho
all right so i do the um
i do the uh what did i do i did dallas
i'll take you through my week
what was it wednesday the [ __ ] is today
my i don't even know so wednesday or
thursday i went to las vegas
um and i did a private show
um they go you got a private show in uh
in
in vegas and i didn't even ask who the
[ __ ] it was for
i was like oh i'm making some money yeah
i'll go to vegas
i'll walk around i'll take a [ __ ]
steam
it's one of my the only time i ever take
a steam is when i go to las vegas
because every [ __ ] casino has one
and um it's the greatest [ __ ]
experience of your life
you know you walk in first of all
everybody in there is always like 80
years old
for some reason old guys love taking a
steep
the only time you ever [ __ ] go in
there right so i always go in there
and uh you got to go in there also with
like an extra towel because
as you're sweating the impurities out
all the impurities are sitting on your
skin and if you don't [ __ ] wipe towel
off
you just absorb them back in or a lot of
them the ones that don't drip off of you
or whatever
so you [ __ ] go in there you have a
great goddamn time
you and some other like [ __ ] guy
looks like mr hooper from [ __ ] sesame
street
you know and uh
you come out your [ __ ] paws are open
you [ __ ] shave you're not gonna have
to shave for like another three days
unless you're one of those hairy apes
and then you go upstairs you take a
[ __ ] nap you sleep like a goddamn
baby
right unfortunately i came in too late
so i wasn't able to do all this
um so anyways typical me like an [ __ ]
i'm one of those some community
comedians are really organized
and then you have other comedians like
myself where as i'm going to the airport
and either nia or the taxi guy is going
what airline i'm looking it up in my
phone
um so i get there and i go who am i
doing this
this uh this private show for and they
said oh it's uh
it's a poker tournament with a bunch of
oilmen
there's like 10 billionaires the rest
are millionaires and there's a couple of
bankers there
right so here i am now feeling like
[ __ ] beyonce
you know when she performed for those
dictators after all my time
talking about uh
you know blood money and all that [ __ ]
here i am going out there i should have
put on a little glitter dress and dance
like a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and i go out to go do this benefit
right because i just said yes because i
saw the money so right now
all my credibility you know beyond me
being a [ __ ] is out the window at this
point because i still did the gig
right so i go down and i do the gig and
uh
i got the funniest the weirdest [ __ ]
applause break
i actually had a great time and i
enjoyed afterwards i was shooting the
[ __ ] with a couple they were [ __ ]
hilarious
like just their whole perspective being
in hollywood that is so goddamn liberal
to then perform for these oil men and
you know they're talking about
you know i was making fun of them
talking about fracking
and like what the [ __ ] it works i don't
give a [ __ ]
you know poisons the water supply
i ain't drinking it and they're all
laughing
and i made some sort of reference to a
bird
covered in oil and then i just started
doing this
rednecky character going well what the
[ __ ] you know how to fly get out of the
oil you dumb [ __ ]
dude applause break
i thought they were gonna get mad i was
kind of breaking their balls they
thought
it was [ __ ] hilarious
and this doesn't make them any worse
than anybody else
that just like everybody i meet on the
road they are
100 immersed in the deal
that makes them still be able to put
fruit loops on the table
so anything positive about it they
[ __ ] love and and
that's what i've found that's what i've
learned through traveling
is that people love their own deal and
they think that their deal
is the only deal and it's the only way
to go and anybody who's against it
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and that includes
includes the most liberal [ __ ] people
on the planet
you know if you listen to liberals
talking about police officers and that
type of [ __ ] like they
they do like reverse fox news
you know so
so i did that gig and uh
had a [ __ ] great time
and then i flew to dallas the next day
did it uh um did a youtube video
made one of those tours of the city had
a great time there [ __ ] show was
amazing
crowds were unbelievable it's a
combination of crowds being unbelievable
and i've done so many shows so i'm
really
on my [ __ ] game you know i'm not like
going up there shaking the rest off
trying to figure out what comes next
i've just been on my [ __ ] game
and um
okay well i remember what i was talking
about trying to get to like how out of
the loop i am
so i'm driving down it's me versey and
tom lewis
the guy who films all of my uh tours of
cities
we're driving down to austin texas going
down the 35
eastbound down loaded up here [ __ ] um
and tom tom's like this [ __ ]
like he just researches everything so
we're on our way down he goes
he's like there's this insane bakery
because me and dumb paul version we were
just gonna go to an ihop
you know get pigs in the blanket it's
just you know whipped cream on his
dumb [ __ ] you could get 10 feet from
your own house
you know so he goes no he goes if you
guys can just hang in there another 10
minutes away
is this place called the the check shop
like czechoslovakia and they have these
[ __ ] insane
um breakfast foods and all this type of
[ __ ] right so we go down there
and um i walk in there okay
and i can instantly tell it's not a
chain or maybe there's a couple left
i don't know maybe there's a chain i
have no [ __ ] idea i go in there all i
know is i see a bunch of locals
sitting there standing in line lines out
the [ __ ] door basically and i'm like
all right this is going to be some good
[ __ ]
and they make all like these little like
breakfast sandwiches
i'm trying to find this thing here and
this is what i ordered i ordered a hot
chubby with
cheese
and i have not been able to say that
without laughing i snickered when i
ordered it
it was a spicy sausage in like this this
honey
bun with like cheese in there
and uh little chex bakery
and this is what this one it's right in
waco or water texas i'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'm sitting there and i'm watching
all these people walking in there like
three four five people are dressed all
in black
red ribbons and i'm going and i'm
sitting there eating it with versey
right a couple of morons sitting there
girl these people either just came from
a
wedding or a funeral i'm guessing it's a
funeral look at that look at misery on
that face
and then tom gets in the car and he
tells us that we're literally like an
eighth of a mile from where the [ __ ]
place exploded
i've never felt so [ __ ] dumb
in my life like this is like one of the
biggest stories in the country
i'm sitting here an eighth of a mile
from it
people are coming from funerals for
loved ones and i'm eating a [ __ ]
spicy chubby with cheese going oh they
go for a wedding or a funeral
that guy looks kind of sad my face
actually turned red
from embarrassment embarrassment of my
own [ __ ] stupidity
um it's [ __ ] horrific
there's no there's no really there's
nothing funny about that story
what i'm basically asking you guys is
why do you tune in every week
if you're gonna listen to somebody this
dumb all right and with that
asking you why you tune in every week we
got some advertising
uh legalzoom.com everybody
all right look you got to have a plan
for your future
you do financial planning you get
insurance
uh but to get to peace of mind you've
got to make sure your family
is also legally protected so where do
you turn for affordable legal protection
you can trust
simple legalzoom.com for up to 12 years
they've been helping americans get
personalized wills
power of attorney legal trust and real
estate documents and more
legalzoom also helps start and maintain
businesses within corporations and llc
filings trademarts and copyrights the
whole deal
their time-saving service was developed
by a team of experienced attorneys
and legalzoom takes care of you from
stat to finish legalzoom documents
is one of the greatest points here
legalzoom documents have been accepted
by courts and government agencies in
all 50 states all right
legalzoom is not a law firm but they can
be they can contact you
whoops they can connect you sorry to an
attorney and provide
self-help services at your specific
direction for even more savings
enter bur b-u-r-r in the referral box at
check-out
if you're a parent or an entrepreneur
don't wait any longer
call or visit legalzoom.com and protect
what's yours
all right there's onesie and here's
number 2z
you all know it i don't know how many
times they got to keep saying it people
sit down today look in the mirror and
ask yourself one question
why do i keep going to the post office
why would i keep going to the post
office when i can do everything at home
with what bill what can i use stamps.com
stamps.com you'll never have to go to
the post office again it's phenomenal
you get
you can get official us postage for any
letter or package
using your own computer and printer uh
no need for one of those expensive
postage meters
stamps.com offers more features than a
meter at a fraction of the cost
no hidden fees or long-term meter
commitments save up to 80 percent
compared to a meter plus you'll never
have to go to the post office again
in fact stamps.com offers special
postage discounts
you can get even you can't even get at
the post office
i use stamps.com to send out all my dvds
and i ladies and gentlemen
i'm a [ __ ] if i can figure out how to
use that scale
and use my printer you can too so don't
be intimidated if you're an oldie like
me
right now use my last name bur b-u-r-r
for this special offer no risk trial
plus 110
bonus offer includes a digital scale and
up to 55 dollars free postage
don't wait go to stamps.com before you
do anything else click on the microphone
at the top of the home page and type in
bur
b-u-r-r that's stamp stop comm enter bur
all righty that was painless
at least it was well you had to listen
to my reading so i guess
you know i'll go [ __ ] yourself uh
let me close this out here yes i don't
want to save that
hey when you download stuff like this
does it slow down your computer after a
while should i be like erasing these
reads every week
um all right let's get to some questions
for this week everybody
um dear bill really enjoy your humor in
the podcast well thank you very much
that's very kind to you but please stop
telling people to pay off their homes
and to not refinance when the bank calls
with the new loan vehicle that saves the
money
and is a no-brainer i am a real estate
appraiser oh what of course you are you
[ __ ] you're in the business
if these people stop refinancing i'll be
out of a job oh i get it now
i just turned 50 and have no other
skills so unless that i can open for you
on the road
what do you say we take it easy on this
fragile economy and keep a lid on the
unemployment
thanks so to save your job
you want me to look the other way and
tell all these people to [ __ ]
refinance
and even though they're six seven years
into their mortgage you want me to start
them
right back at the beginning at payment
number one
for 30 years you know at least they're
with all that front-ended loaded
interest started all over again
you know you're kind of blaming the
victims here
i don't understand how we all ended up
under the thumb of these bankers
i could see if they initially started
off
with uh mixed martial art training
and then after they won the championship
they then got into banking then i could
see why
everyone would be so afraid of bankers
but the fact that they're just a bunch
of pencil pushing jack when's the last
time you saw a tough banker
and i'm not saying they're not out there
because i know i'll get emails dude you
see this guy
down at the local branch this kid could
have gone
pro that left [ __ ] tackle but he blew
out his knee
um
are you actually trying to tell me that
that it doesn't save them money
that's that's the illusion of it it
lowers your your your mortgage payment
for the month but it prolongs your
interest and in the long haul
you end up paying way more money and
you're asking me to co-sign
off on like years more of indentured
servitude to these banker [ __ ] i can't
do that
i have ethics i do private shows for oil
men and bankers
listen sir if you can tell me if you can
write me back let's listen we'll make
this a two-parter
if you can write me back and tell me how
that's saving them money and don't do
that while they were paying
two grand a month for their mortgage and
now their minimum payment is 1700 so
it's 300 off i want you to do
do the math go through the 30 years of
it and their interest and all that okay
you're not going to be able to
write me back and say that they're
saving money they're not it's a [ __ ]
over
and it's a very easy [ __ ] over to read
that when the bank reaches out to you
and says hey you want to save money
hey listen we were sitting here trying
to figure out how we could make
less money off of you it's a [ __ ] over
all right i've already done my filthy
deed this week
tap dancing for a bunch of [ __ ] oil
men
you know how the [ __ ] am i kidding what
am i supposed to do
you know do have i come up with some
sort of alternative
[ __ ] source to help your car going
i don't know whatever sir i'm one of the
biggest hypocrites you're ever going to
find
i know your deal you want people to
refinance so they can what continue
making their
their payments listen whether i tell
them to do that or not
like none of the laws got changed and
the banks got these houses back
to do it all over again i told you that
story a few weeks ago
the guy who sold me my house he goes
dude you bought it the perfect time you
can get like another 50 grand for your
house if you sold it today
he goes the market's exploding and he
goes i've never seen anything like this
it's like what are you talking about
you've been selling houses for 10 years
you've lived through the [ __ ] biggest
bubble ever
and you know oh yeah you think so he
doesn't give a [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] so don't [ __ ]
come at me with your hat in your hand
and talk about this fragile economy when
you know what you're doing out there all
right with your [ __ ] three-card money
jesus that got a little [ __ ]
kind of little uh little chippy
all right hair loss or sex loss bill i'm
sure you've heard of propecia
heard of it i used it
i used it and when i ran out of it i
just had that honest moment with myself
and i was just like there's no way
there's not going to be a side effect
okay there's always there's no way
there's just no way there's no way this
thing
okay i'll save my hair but damage my
liver
you know what do i need more you know a
full head of hair
or a functioning [ __ ] liver you just
you know you just gotta bite the bullet
and turn and just turn old just age
gracefully you know i try to keep my
hair short
i try to offend as little people as i go
through the slow process of seeing what
my skull actually looks like
he goes i have a lot of friends on it
that say it sort of works
definitely slows down hair loss by doing
something however apparently
the drawbacks is no boner
oh is that i don't know i don't know
either way on that one that's uh that's
some bar room stuff
i think that it that can that can happen
to some people
i have no [ __ ] idea he said so do you
choose hair
to get sex or choose no hair which might
mean no sex
is this some sort of sick joke by the
pharmaceutical companies
no you you're fighting nature listen
dude i'll tell you right now
all right there's women out there that
think a shaved head
is sexy not all of them but there's
enough
all right there's enough out there that
you can keep going out banging women
you know some women find a shaved head
[ __ ] they they like it
turns them on so listen this is the
great thing
about women is they can see beyond
what you look like okay if you come in
there and you got a little swagger
and you're funny and you're [ __ ] you
know
shaved head shows confidence dude you're
like [ __ ] it
preemptive strike you guys are walking
out on me well you know what i'm kicking
you out the door
and you take out your clippers
you know i buzzed my head down a few
years ago i [ __ ] loved it and i took
all the jokes uh when you cancer
patiently [ __ ] make a wish
peter's out after a couple weeks you
know
i don't know i go back and forth i go
back and forth i mean
i go literally from doing maybe i'll do
the [ __ ] hair transplant
to all the way back to i'll [ __ ]
shave my head again
i have no idea but i got to be honest
with you dude it it doesn't
the vibe you're bringing is going to be
way more listen do you really want to
get with some girl who's with you
because you have a [ __ ]
a nice big cow lick on top of your
[ __ ] head and if you didn't have it
then she wouldn't be with you
you know going bald is like driving a
piece of [ __ ]
car it really keeps the [ __ ] away from
you
all these [ __ ] idiots with full heads
of hair driving around
flashy cars you see what happens to him
what happened to mel gibson
he should have just gone bald but he
didn't he kept fighting it doing [ __ ] up
there
drove around in a flashy car i had to
give up my [ __ ] lacquer tickets
you know flipping out flipping up
you know what dude yeah don't take those
[ __ ] drugs those drugs are brand new
and the side effects that they're
talking about i'm telling you is just
the [ __ ] that they're letting on
to cover their asses that they said that
there was some side effects
okay from what i've overheard in bars
the people on the fda half of them used
to work for these pharmaceutical [ __ ]
companies so they got the nuts running
the [ __ ] nut house
all right and you're just gonna be again
you're gonna be a little lab rat if you
start taking that [ __ ]
all right so i would suggest not doing
it let nature take its [ __ ] course
and do what i'm doing wait for the cure
and i guarantee you it ain't gonna come
so just [ __ ] man up and go bald your
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay do what i'm doing just slowly let
it happen
ah a year from now i'm gonna have
[ __ ] hair plugs and i'm gonna be
performing for dictators for a new
year's eve give
new year's eve be best friends with
beyonce
i didn't see my itinerary either i
didn't know who it was
i literally used the same excuse for
performing for oilmen
um anyways loner hey there red-haired
reindeer
um love everything you do
and listen to you as your as you always
changed my life ah jesus all right now
this one isn't going to be on me
love everything you do and listening to
you oh has changed my life sorry that is
on me
however although i am more comfortable
being myself now than i was before i
listen to you i've got a dilemma
i don't know why but i don't leave a
lasting impression on people
oh god dude that's one of the saddest
things ever you just said you're
forgettable
hey you know what you should do you
should turn to a life of crime
you know don't hurt anybody just go in
with an unloaded gun and start robbing
convenience stores
right get the money you take off and
then [ __ ] when the cops come can you
give us a description
yeah you know that's the funny thing
about him you know he just
i don't know if it's because i was so
scared or the fact that he just
was just so forgettable i
okay i know he had an arm because he was
in a hand because he was holding
uh anyways i go to a community college
and for some re
unknown reason my personality doesn't
attract anyone i lost all my friends
from high school they all moved on with
their lives
and the people in my college don't
notice me
i'm very eccentric jesus christ dude you
sound like you should be on some list
here man
please tell me that you're not gonna
[ __ ] start reading about chemicals
all right because at work everyone loves
my crazy ass personality my spontaneity
but these two-faced [ __ ] are such liars
they always say oh we should hang out
but every monday i always hear about
their stories of them going out without
me
i've tried to make plans but they easily
flake
please bill your podcast keeps me sane
and you can only make sense of this
um p.s you know that polite fake
personality everyone has when they first
meet someone
what if a girl has that personality only
around you
and no one else is she uncomfortable
with you or likes you
oh jesus dude jesus um all right
[ __ ]
oh how do i [ __ ] kind of why do i how
do i re-enter this [ __ ] atmosphere
without
burning up um
listen this is what you got to do okay
you can't give a [ __ ] whether people
hang out with you
or not all right i if i
if i had to guess i'd say maybe you're
trying too hard
you know take a deep breath just [ __ ]
relax
come in on monday say what's up to
people and go about your business
that's what i would do all right and
stop trying to hang out with them
you know take this new [ __ ] relaxed
approach
go into a bar and just be chill don't
have a crazy ass personality and be
spontaneous spontaneous because i think
i'm reading into that you're trying too
hard and you're freaking people out
just [ __ ] chill all right just
[ __ ] chill out
and relax if that girl has a fake
personality around you that does not
mean she likes you
i think you're freaking people out a
little bit i'm not trying to
criticize you here i think you're just
trying too hard because the fact that
your friends from high school took off
from you
you might be you might be a little
self-conscious so now you're questioning
who you are
and you're trying to [ __ ] amp ramp up
to this energy level that you're not
normally at so it's weirding people out
so i would just [ __ ] chill you know
but but please do not [ __ ] go to work
and do something crazy
because there's a lot of that [ __ ] in
there that made me [ __ ] worried about
you
all right just
[ __ ] i'm telling you just like i said
that dude going bald just [ __ ] go
bald
you know somebody makes a joke about it
you laugh yeah it's [ __ ] awful
god bless you and you're full out of
hair and then [ __ ] make fun of this
shirt
there you go uh i hope that helped out
sir all right all right viking twins
and oh geez viking twins and jesus bill
i know you're tired of relationship
advice but this may
but maybe this will be different um
here's the deal
i'm having goddamn twins in september
well congratulations
i've been married for nearly six years
now i love my wife
and i'm definitely stoked on having
children with her however
while she is a christian i am not and i
am a little concerned
and then when he what is he right all
[ __ ]
greedy how [ __ ] ready
he wrote that he wrote that all as one
word everybody if you think i'm dumb
and he wrote he wrote all is a-l
no spaces okay stop rolling your eyes
feeling that you're smarter than me um
he says i'm a little concerned about
what our kids
are going to learn if we decide to go to
church and whatnot
i'm just not sure that i want my
children to learn about hell and sin and
all that other [ __ ]
um that's just not a story for [ __ ]
kids you know like
you'll be bet you better be good or when
you [ __ ] die you're gonna burn for
goddamn eternity
i want my kids to be happy i don't want
them expecting a [ __ ] slap from some
imaginary figure
if they tell a [ __ ] lie or something
kids should be innocent and full of
wonder
and gay and all that [ __ ] you know
that's so funny how guys
can't just write happy stuff you gotta
somehow tap out you know they should be
happy they should go sledding and all
that [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know we always got to do that anyhow
i'm not exactly sure
what nia believes but you guys but if
you guys had kid
would this be an issue for you too no
neither one of us goes to church
um another so we're gonna go to hey yo
um another problem is that either way
sucks if they believe in hell
they'll live in fear if the little
[ __ ] believe what i believe
they'll think they're just gonna goddamn
rotten the [ __ ] ground and disappear
when they die
so they'll be bitter cynical and [ __ ]
miserable just like their father
now i disagree with that because i think
you just go into the ground
that's what i think but that's not why
i'm bitter and cynical
i'm bitter and cynical because of like
that [ __ ] email that i got from that
50 year old real estate guy
who wants me to side with the banker
[ __ ] and no one will pick up an axe
and go into these gated communities and
get these pencil pushing
[ __ ] you know
and every [ __ ] week we work and we
gotta take our [ __ ] check and take it
down to the goddamn bank and give it to
him
you know acting like this is a safer
place to have
than stuffing it in your mattress you
know
you might as well stuff it in a mattress
you're never gonna walk it and your
mattress is gonna have a lock on it be
like yeah
[ __ ] that's closed go [ __ ] yourself
and i know what other people are saying
well you know
what if somebody breaks into your house
does anybody look under the mattress at
this point it's such a cliched place
to put a couple hundred bucks you know i
don't [ __ ] know you can't with that's
why i'm cynical
that's why i'm cynical okay because
you know i'll talk to hockey fans okay
and they'll have the biggest dirtbag
piece of [ __ ] intent to injure guy on
their team but because he plays for them
they don't give a [ __ ] and they'll put
him in their ring of honor
and then if somebody does something to
their team then they're flipping out
going that guy should be out of the
league
that's why i get bitter and cynical
is because it's depressing it's
depressing that
that the amount of people that just look
out their own heads
and you know if it's good for me then
it's [ __ ] good and i don't give a
[ __ ]
and they uh you know they lack
uh empathy that's why but not because
you're going into the [ __ ] ground so
i i wouldn't equate it to that
um anyways my solution thus far
is just to go north you know no i don't
die
in [ __ ] battle die in [ __ ] battle
sons and you'll get to be members of the
inner heart jar i don't know this is
some lord of the rings [ __ ] fight and
die every day only to be resurrected at
night
to feast with odin and valhalla i don't
know what any of this
is something when you and your fellow
ghost warriors fight the [ __ ] wolf
and
for fenrir until the end of time
that's a badass speech if i knew how to
[ __ ] pronounce it that's one of those
things where you're walking around with
that thing on your arm for a falcon to
land on
and when you go to shake hands you grab
the other guy's forearm
he goes i think that's the way to go i
have absolutely no idea how to really
relay these concerns to my wife without
offending her yeah i mean
considering you're writing me i get it
but i think i care enough about my kids
to make this an issue
my kids are going to be complete
completely mediocre
and never accomplish anything then
there's no need to heat
oh what my kids are going to be
completely mediocre and never
accomplished anything there's no need to
keep
hell on that pile what do you think
all right well i was with you until you
said your kids are going to be mediocre
you can't say that to them you got to
give them that head start you got to
build them up
you see now i got and i got to talk to
you about two things um
i mean i don't know you're really far
down the [ __ ] road six years in and
now you're having kids to finally bring
up
the religious issue this is really
something that should have been
discussed before you got married but i
get it you fell in love with this person
you can't pick who you fall in love with
as they say
um
i i would just sit down and tell her
what you told me and then when she was
like well why did you bring this up
60 years ago use the line i just said
just say because i love you i saw you
and i i there's nothing i could do i
fell in love with you
i think you're great and you know now i
just want to discuss this with you
and i'd like to do it without you crying
and making me feel like a bully because
i i
you know these are half my kids too
so what if once a week every every other
week you scared the [ __ ] out of them
and every other week we go into the
backyard and i dig a hole and go that's
where you end up
you can sort of balance it out um
yeah dude i don't know i don't know how
to do it other than you just have to sit
down and talk to her
and just say listen i don't mind
spirituality i don't mind you know
believing in a higher power and
everything but i really think it's a lot
to heap on the whole heaven and health
thing
and uh i think when they're young enough
when they go to church they're just
going to be bored and not know what
people are talking about
and i think it'd be a great thing for
their self-esteems if you and i didn't
drive away
and try to communicate all that hell
[ __ ] to him
all right maybe
think she can still take them to church
but just keep reinforcing
that this thing loves them all right
that is a [ __ ] up thing to just bring
that into their lives you're gonna burn
forever
have fun playing frisbee um all right
pro flowers everybody mother's day is
coming up
huh who's better than your mom no one
all right did you give your mom a hard
time growing up of course you did
of course you did were you like me did
you get into a fight with your brother
you went after he slapped you in the
back of the head and you grabbed the
garden hose and you tried to spray at
him
through the [ __ ] screen of the
kitchen and you flooded the kitchen
right then your mother came out with a
wooden spoon and beat it over your head
until it snapped in half did you do that
of course you did isn't it time
did you take out the car and wrap it
around a pole
then they got sued by the family that
[ __ ] makes the telephone poles of
course you did
don't you think it's time something that
may be uh
are they giving me like suggestions here
i know to make it funny
look at these suggestions talk about how
you're making up
for it by sending her profile i'm not
going to talk about stuff that's not
going on in my life i'm going to talk
about the fact that i love my mom
and i love my girlfriend so i'm going to
get them flowers
is there an easier way to do it than
proflowers.com
absolutely not pro flowers has one dozen
rainbow roses for 19.99
or you can double the roses and get
chocolates plus a premium pink vase for
just 29.98 that's 50 percent off
you just need my code burp b-u-r-r when
you order to get these special prices
you get a colorful bouquet of roses or
is it bouquet is it bouquet
of roses that will make your mom smile
this offer is just for my radio
listeners
um it's a listener favorite every year
come on man you guys got to do more than
just send your mother a card
women love flowers you know and she's
going to love that you care
even though you've gotten older and
you're married you're still remembering
dear old mom
profiles are guaranteed to last a full
week or your money back
you know see if you get a sweater she
wears it one day she puts it in the
drawer
you get the flowers with that beautiful
face she's going to see him all week
all right so here's the deal the only
way to get this amazing mother's day
deal
is to go to proflowers.com click on the
microphone in the top right hand corner
and type in bur
b-u-r-r that's proflowers.com
click on the microphone and type in burr
order now this special
pricing expires soon yeah do it right
now just get it out of the way
and then the pressure of mother's day
you know you're not gonna have to worry
about running out
going to cvs trying to pick out the last
[ __ ] three cards that are left
you don't want to do that all right so
there you go
all right last read here everybody uh
did i already do this one ah jesus there
uh e-voice oh i like this one e-voice is
the reason you're gonna make more money
in 2013. how do you like that for
confidence right out of the gate with
their copy
they are the reason you're gonna make
more money uh when your customers call
you'll have your own toll-free number
professional greeting dial by
name directory and more you'll sound
like a fortune 500 company
and blow away your competitors you'll
sound like a fortune 500 company even
though you only have three employees
you could just have one employee and
they'll make you sound like you got this
giant factory already
and you're somebody to get in business
with e-voice lets you give out one
number that rings wherever you are
the beach the bar it doesn't matter
you'll sound like you're at the office
yeah unless people are screaming in the
background i mean we have to go to yeah
i guess you go into the bathroom
um you got to go to evoice dot com and
use the promo code bill
e-voice takes oh e-voice even takes all
your voicemails
transcribes them and sends them to you
instantly as a text or an email
so you can check your voicemails before
the meeting ends and not look rude
e-voice is only 10 bucks a month for a
long time my listeners have been able to
get free tiles
free tarot of e-voice for six months but
that's about to come to an
end okay so guys make sure you sign up
for your free trial of e-voice
between now and the end of the month
which is literally tomorrow
and get your six-month free trial before
it's too late come on guys i want you to
get you out of them cubicles if you want
all right it's your last chance to try
this great service for free for six
months go to evoice.com
use the promo code bill that's evoice
dot com promo
code bill or just go to the podcast page
on billboard.com and click on the
e-voice banner right now all right there
you go
okay back to the podcast and what better
way to go back to the podcast by reading
this lovely email this lovely email
right here called getting [ __ ] blocked
by
jesus oh geez um
that would be hard he came walking and
performing miracles full head of hair
chris christopherson beard you know he's
got that robe
all the checks oh my god do you have
anything underneath it
um hey bill love the podcast i really
like to hear your thoughts on this
experience
i'm going through with a lady
all right at the end of last summer i
met a girl and we hit it off immediately
she's one of those girls oh wait i
forgot to add i forgot to mention that
i'm going to do a neo log this week a
neolog
i know a lot of people are asking why is
she not doing her podcast
and it's because our house is gutted
right now and she's being an absolute
trooper and she's handling most of the
[ __ ]
as i'm out on the road okay but she's
going to come on and do a neolog this
weekend one of the topics is going to be
the first openly gay athlete
all right i'm going to i'm actually
going to ask you that question about the
shower
um shower love every now and then i get
a little bit something
and something or something um at the end
of last summer back to this guy
cockblocked by jesus
i met a girl and we hit it off
immediately she's one of those girls
who's not only gorgeous and sexy but
she's really cool too
oh top shelf we've got a lot in common
and i'm totally into her
i've seen her regularly since then and
she stayed with me a few nights
uh we've had abs we've had absolutely
mind-blowing sex during those nights
oh jesus dude you're gonna fall hard for
this one i'm already in love with her i
don't even know her
but most importantly we have fun
together and we connect on a personal
level
so i decided to take it to the next
level and
see if she'd be into dating on a wreck
on the regular
since we've been hitting it off so well
that's when it gets interesting
she says she is a christian i on the
other hand
am definitely not a christian although
i've studied religious writings for many
years i don't consider myself to be a
religious person
but since i'm not a christian she's
really reluctant to date
but she'll [ __ ] your brains out dude i
i don't know man i think you you might
just have to enjoy this one
you know it's like renting a car you
can't afford
go out and take it on the highway man
have a good time with it and bring it
back by thursday
um but whatever i'll keep reading here
uh the bible says christians should only
date other christians
the bible says a lot of things that
don't make sense in society now
uh my mother is a catholic and my father
is as non-religious as i am
but they've been happily married for
almost 30 years it irritates the hell
out of me that since i don't love jesus
that she thinks i'm an
unsuitable partner i don't need to love
jesus to know how to be a good gentleman
um i treat her with respect and i'm a
good partner and a friend
what do you think bill literally
everything else about this girl
and how we get along is stellar it's a
[ __ ] shame to let that go
thanks bill and go [ __ ] yourself um
well here's the deal i would present
your argument
and if she still has a [ __ ] problem
with it and she just won't do it then
you know what you got to do
you got to walk away until your heart
gets crushed by this girl or even worse
you talk her into something by just
wearing her down into something she
doesn't want to do
and then you're six years into your
[ __ ] marriage having twins like that
other poor bastard
and you have to have that other problem
that big [ __ ] conversation
okay she's getting older so you know
she's gonna have a couple of kids she's
not gonna be rocking your [ __ ] world
you know what i mean you got a beer
belly so all the looks and all the hot
sex is out the window and now you're
just [ __ ] with this person
all right that you don't line up with
religiously
so that that's that is a big one
that is a big one so that's what i would
do i would sit down and i would present
my argument to her
and um just lay it out there just say
listen i really like you
beyond a physical thing i like you
you know and i'd bring up the thing you
said about your parents and they still
get along
and then just say but look i don't want
to get
emotionally involved with you if you
can't look past the fact that i don't
believe in the bearded baby
um that's how i'd leave it
and then you know what if she has a
[ __ ] problem with that then you walk
you walk all right or what you do
is just hook up with her once every
[ __ ] 10 days
10 to 15 days you hook up with her you
[ __ ] her brains out you have a great
time
and then you know you walk away
you know so you don't get drawn in
like i don't know
being with somebody else it's like uh
the more you see them it's like [ __ ]
eating doritos you know if you just take
a few and you put them on a plate
and then you leave the bag in the
cupboard and you're watching a game you
know you're not going to get up and go
grab the bag
all right but if you [ __ ] got the bag
there you're going to consume the whole
goddamn thing and that's what the [ __ ]
you're going to do with this girl
if you keep hanging out with her all
right you're going to consume the whole
[ __ ] thing
you're going to be totally invested with
your heart and then she's going to walk
away because you don't want to get
[ __ ]
dirty fire ash put on your forehead
every [ __ ] february
then you're going to be crying in the
fetal position and you have to spend
[ __ ] goddamn year or two of your life
trying to cry this [ __ ] out of your
heart you know what i mean sit down and
have this conversation with her
there you go all right netflix
documentaries hey bill just listen to
the
a recent podcast in the podcast you
mentioned that you like documentaries
i love them i absolutely love them
documentaries
are like reading for stupid people you
know you get this like watching a book
uh unless you watch those michael moore
ones or that one that that guy made
about nirvana
you know what i mean like michael morris
should be like considered like video
like op-ed pieces um
you know i i and you can it's easy to
tell i hate to single that guy out but
that guy i think is one of the biggest
offenders of somebody who's just like
already has his mind made up and is
editing around
the opinion that he already has and he's
just you know taking you by the hand and
leading you down to this absolutely
[ __ ]
so ridiculous to one side that guy to me
is as ridiculous as [ __ ] bill
o'reilly
you know i i'd actually say he's more
ridiculous
than bill o'reilly you know what i mean
um anyways i don't like talking politics
here we go
um now i know you say you don't like
football
soccer but i know you love this but i
know you'll love this
it's called the four year plan and it's
about a team called
queens park rangers they had just been
taken over
by a team of billionaires including big
names in formula one
i love by the way i love formula one
racing i never watch it i always miss it
i always somehow the season's weird it
starts in like february or some [ __ ] i
don't know i i always miss it but
formula one racing is like if you're
ever gonna meet
james bond it's gonna be at a formula
formula one race
like you're just talking the richest
people on the planet
the greatest bone structures of any
people you're ever going to see
nothing but full heads of jet black hair
and some of the hottest ass you're ever
going to see in your life
are at these things it's insane
and then what i love about this sport is
is the level
of intelligence to get that card you
just go just a little bit faster
and then it also makes sense that
there's right and left turns
you know and they race in the rain it's
re it's re it's the real [ __ ] deal
i'm a huge fan of it by all means
somebody let me know when the next
formula one races it's not like i can't
go on the internet and find out
uh was it the fuel channel i know
somebody shows them i always wanted to
get that in just one year just
follow it for the whole [ __ ] year
you know the ferrari team and all those
[ __ ]
mercedes and all those great car
manufacturers anyways here we go somehow
someone persuaded
these formula one people to allow a tv
crew to record everything
which is basically them owning this uh
this soccer club
um in a nutshell it turns out to show
exactly how not to run a club
spoiler alert here we go this
documentary may change how you see
football
by the way i'm from birmingham england
england and i support
aston villa my apologies because i know
i probably said that wrong
i really don't know why i've told you
this but please watch it it's fantastic
oh absolutely i would i would love to
watch that i'd watch one on
on uh world cup soccer i i like world
cup soccer that the whole world
is watching and it really is a world
championship when you win it
you know those [ __ ] horns that they
were blowing that really
blew it for me uh last time
i remember trying to watch it i was in
vegas with tom papa and uh
he had this show at the orleans and it
was me and him doing this
this comedy show that was such a [ __ ]
great weekend
so i brought the lovely nia with me and
we both went up to uh
to his suite and we were watching i was
actually psyched that i found
another an american that was into the
soccer and we were sitting there
watching it and that stupid [ __ ]
horns being blown the entire time
it just became this running joke is he's
tom started imitating him just kept
going
i came up with some sort of jerry lewis
kind of [ __ ] noise
and we would just be trying to focus on
the game and every three minutes one of
us would do our impression
of those horns and somehow it stayed
funny for the entire [ __ ] match
and uh but
that really that really hurt the world
cup like those horns should be banned um
so anyways whatever
whatever i'm saying i'm gonna watch that
one did you say what it was called
yeah you did it's called the four year
plan i'm definitely going to watch that
all right hey billy boy just wanted to
give you a couple of good documentaries
to watch
on netflix oh look at me i think i hit i
hit a nerve
i hit an artery people are enjoying
um just want to give you a couple of
good documentaries to watch on netflix
i am the first one the imposter
is a really good one also the wild and
wonderful whites
of west virginia is absolutely hilarious
you know i started to watch that one
and it's really fascinating but
there's there's something about watching
people who are poor
at a certain point poor and uneducated i
have to shut it off
because it it feels like uh i don't know
it's like watching that that
here comes honey boo boo i started to
watch an episode of it
and you know i was kind of laughing
along and everything but when they went
to this
that auction and they were they were
basically auctioning off food that
grocery stores couldn't legally sell
you know it was kind of past the
expiration date or
and then they were bidding on like old
cookies and [ __ ]
now there's no way there could have been
meat because you could kill somebody so
i know that
maybe it was something about it was food
that
the grocery stores couldn't sell these
people were so broke
that they were buying they were bidding
on week old cookies
and then like high-fiving and excited
when they won the auction like they just
bought a [ __ ] shelby or something
i have to shut it off so uh but it is
fascinating
um what the other one is he said one
more is called
unguarded the story of chris herron
heron i don't know how to say it he he
was a badass high school basketball
player out of boston
who threw his career away on drugs um
ugh that's another rough one i like
watching the ones where people they win
in the end
you know but i'll watch that when he
says love the podcast and you stand up
go [ __ ] yourself
all right that is the podcast for this
week everybody uh i hope you enjoyed it
and um i have to tell you man this was
one of the most amazing months in my
stand-up career
all these beautiful venues that i got to
perform in it's really a blessing to be
able to uh do stand up
at a theater and um i wanted to thank
everybody that that is that has come out
to my shows this month and i i really
learned something
this month about all these so-called b
and c
level cities like though they're the
[ __ ]
and um you know people are so [ __ ]
appreciative when you come out to him
you know i'm not talking like dallas and
austin and that type of thing i'm
talking about when you go to like
tallahassee
you know i mean it's so ridiculous i
guess last week i kept calling columbia
but charleston south carolina that i
went to
i mean that's an a level city they had
like [ __ ] houses with nine
million dollars right on the water but
like just people don't go to them
um we actually i know that i mentioned
that i was going to do a tour of canada
and we were going to do it in the
summertime and we realized how stupid
that was
that uh you know you know i've done a
lot of stuff for the nhl
going on a radio show and everything
well if we really need to promote this
thing because i haven't toured canada
and i don't want to be in front of 40
people every show so we took that tour
we moved it
to january of 2014 during hockey season
where i can actually promote the things
so i don't go to [ __ ] thunder bay
and stand in front of two people but
so that's kind of a bad thing if you
wanted me to come to canada so i
apologize because i know i said i was
going to be there but
we are putting together a tour of all
these
the flyover states in place of that in
uh
july and uh
some of the dates are going to be like
boise idaho
i i know i got a date or two in montana
the last state i need to pro
to go to then i've been to all 50.
i remember hearing deadwood kansas i
think oklahoma
some places in colorado that aren't
denver because i always go to the comedy
works so i'm gonna try to get out there
and maybe do another bus tour and hit
all these places that uh
that i've never been to and you know i i
have people come up to me at the end of
my shows go man
i drove four hours i drove six hours in
like these insane i drove here from
[ __ ] iowa
and uh you know so i think it's about
time that i [ __ ] drove out to where
they're at
so that's gonna be happening in july
i'll let you guys know about the dates
as soon as they get solidified and once
again
thank you to everybody came that's how
[ __ ] great this tour was i actually
you know i ended up in um
in kansas city at the midland theater
and the promoter's girlfriend
made all these cookies with my name on
them
and said the midland theater thanking me
for coming out was one of the nicest
[ __ ] things
anybody has ever done um
for me you know what's so funny i have
such a [ __ ] sweet tooth she made like
20 of them i took them all home i stuck
them in my luggage
and uh some of them broke but i have
such a sweet tooth i
put them in this [ __ ] tupperware even
poured the crumbs in there
so uh my battle for of not being old
billy fatface i'm [ __ ] losing it but
uh
so and as much as i appreciated that
please somebody else don't do it to me
because i'll become a tub of [ __ ] if
somebody gives me cookies after every
[ __ ] show cause i'll i'll eat all of
them
it's an embarrassing weakness that i
have um all right that's the podcast for
this week um
for people who want to get into the nhl
the nhl playoffs
start tomorrow i believe
april 30th and i'm going to [ __ ] i'm
ride or die with my bruins and i'm
hoping just something because it's the
playoffs that they can somehow put
together three good periods
um i don't give a [ __ ] i'll always watch
them i love them go [ __ ] yourselves
that's the podcast i'll see you
next week there
you